[Musique]
la traque
un homme équipé d'au moins deux ans il a
tué deux fois avant tiers des moyens
considérables sont déployés des
hélicoptères quadrillaient toujours le
ciel est au sol les militaires vérifie
chaque véhicule
la gendarmerie diffuse également depuis
ce matin sur les réseaux sociaux
cet appel à témoins valentin c'est papa
je t'aime j'ai la garantie qu'il n'y
aura pas feu
si tu te rends maintenant mon fils c'est
moi confiance je t'aime
nous sommes tous avec toi la
civilisation c'est un vernis sur un
océan de barbarie potentiel et de
sauvagerie potentiel c'est ça les
sociétés
donc quand le vernis craque évidemment
ça va très mal et dans une société comme
la nôtre le vernis c'est quoi c'est
l'idée républicaine
l'idée démocratique et le respect des
valeurs de liberté
le coronavirus jusque sur le toit du
monde à plus de 5300 mètres d'altitude
le camp de base de l'everest a vu ces
derniers jours au moins 35 personnes
contaminées être rapatriés vers la
capitale népalaise c'est dans ce stade
ici atlanta que les premiers enfants ont
été vaccinés les caméras attendait les
familles à la sortie chara les montres
monde entier je me sens bien après cette
piqûre
je suis content de l'avoir eue pour
faire plein de choses là plutôt que de
rester à la maison à ne rien faire je
pense que les enfants oui il faudra
aller vacciner
on suivra les recommandations de la has
que je viens de mentionner impôts le
moment en france
elle n'a pas donné encore d'avis sur la
question aux états unis vous l'avez
rappelé dans d'autres ne le lie au
canada 2 à partir de 12 ans on peut
vacciner et celles recommandées
mais selon un sondage seulement un tiers
des parents concernés se disent prêts à
vacciner les enfants puis dans non on ne
connaît pas très bien les effets de ce
vaccin je ne pense pas que des enfants
aussi jeunes doivent être vaccinés il ya
trop d'inconnues
si vous marchez à lunel ne soyez pas
surpris ce genre de message peut
retentir
ici pas de lunel me demandent de porter
votre masque pour vous protéger et
protéger les autres sous peine de
verbalisation
merci injonction au port du masque mais
aussi au ramassage des déjections
canines et aux déchets la mission
d'inspection a rendu ses premières
conclusions ce matin elle parle d'une
série de défaillances et de
dysfonctionnements
on croirait entendre une annonce de
gares pour annoncer le retard d'un train
si vous vous étiez donner les moyens
d'appliquer des lois que vous avez
vous-même voter
ma question est donc simple n'avez vous
pas honte d'une telle inefficacité de
votre politique
trois haut parleurs couplée à des
caméras de surveillance installées en
centre ville
elles sont reliées ici dans ce centre de
contrôle géré par la police municipale
steve est l'un des six opérateurs
capables de déclencher les messages il
fait juste de cliquer dessus
ça nous ouvre à une petite fenêtre et là
on sélectionne le message on n'a plus
qu'à appuyer sur play et ça envoie et sa
diffusent le message dans la rue ce qui
parfois me fait honte c'est
l'exploitation c'est l'exploitation
c'est l'exploitation cynique cynique et
obscène d'une situation que nous avons
tous à déplorer je les ai connus comme
fauconnier donc et je peux vous dire que
les faucons crécerelles s'en souviennent
et dont il est redoutable mais là
franchement je lui ai dit non
allez dans votre ministère abandonné
cccc cette idée de faire justice sur un
terrain de jeu